I believe in time travel I believe
people have done it I believe people
have done it and when I was in Arizona I
think I saw I I saw a time traveler
let's go and I only talked about on the
ver effect and then the worker hold on
the worker the guy that was security at
the comedy club in Phoenix was with me
so here's How The Story Goes what Comedy
Club CB live CB live in Phoenix the same
guys that own standup live and the one
in uh what's the Tempe okay Joel batoff
Joe yes Joel and Matt Con yes yes so I'm
doing their club and it was like middle
of pandemic but kind of right when
pandemic start is starting to lighten
right and I'm there and there was a
table of my fans to the left paying
their bill too loud and being disruptive
and I only have about 15 minutes left in
the set I'm doing about an hour and 10
and I'm like guys dude you gotta like
I'm trying I'm like guys [__] what the
[__] there's 40 SP and one guy goes
whatever ver man [__] you were're trying
to and then it got crazy and the
security guy came came over and then it
got nuts they stood up [__] you no [__]
you so me and the security guy had a
bond B right oh God I hate it was during
a I hate when that happened it was at
the end of the show and it sucked
because it was fans and then it turned
into [__] you verie because they got mad
that I go guys you're because they were
just two of them were obl like just
obliterate right so I say to the guy hey
you want to get a cigar I like cuz
that's you know that's what I do on the
road I I'll go I'll go get a glass the
guy that worked at the club the security
the security that came yeah he's a
future person and and I go like no no no
no no he's not the fut person he's not
the he's not the time traveler okay he's
with me thank God cuz you guys would be
like this [__] vers is out of his
[__] mind all right so we go to this
we go to this lounge and we're sitting
there and we're talking comedies telling
me stories about people that he's you
know sit other situations he had at the
club and a dude walks in and he's
fullon 20s outfit right fullon 20s and
he's got the hat and he's got the vest
and he's got the clock and he's got the
shoe and he's walking with a limp and a
cane now mind you it's about 11 o'clock
at night okay and he just walks in and
it's just me and the security guy and
this bartender and he walks in and we
kind of just look and I'm just going
like like your back where you are now
was the guy I was with and he's coming
that way so I just go dude there's a
[__] dude I go look at this so we
walk in and um I'm my dude that
mannequin I dude I'm not joking I
thought there was a black dude sitting
right there for I'm not even joking that
just freaked me the [__] out dude I was
like you got a [__] shy producer like
what the [__] is that dude so so like so
uh we're we're sitting there and I go
look at this guy the guy walks up and
he's walking with the cane really like
good and but fullon 20s and he walks up
to the bar and he goes hey how you doing
he does this hat thing how you doing
gentlemen and I go oh that's some get up
you got there oh thank you so much and
he's talking very he's talking very like
mature weird right like whatever maybe
this guy's acting whatever actor well
maybe went to college no no no no one
dude if he went to college dressed like
that they would have kicked the [__] out
of him okay okay okay so this is
different so he goes up and he asks for
a drink and a cigar and the bartender is
like Hey we're closing in 15 minutes and
he goes oh okay and he takes a whiskey
and he CHS and he starts he starts
walking away now me and the dude the
dude Adrian were looking and he goes up
the stairs like perfectly with this cane
and he's all dressed and go hey take
care and he just walks away into the
parking lot and kind of just disappears
right okay so the guy says I go what
what happened with that guy he goes dude
that was [__] weird man he goes the
bartender goes that was that was really
I go yeah it seemed a little but
whatever we let it go the guy says he
can't smoke we got a cloth but if you go
across the street to the bar you could
sit outside and drink and finish your
cigars there we go there yeah and now
we're sitting there we're kind of
talking about and sure enough we see
this guy coming down again and he's just
walking and he walks past us and we go
hey man hey we so he goes oh gentlemen
yes how you doing again and he's like
like that so we start talking to him and
we're like What do you do and he goes oh
well I'm a silent actor and I'm also a
locksmith or like he said some some job
and he goes yeah and go what's up with
your limp he goes oh I I fell on my I
fell on my gun during the move during
the a scene and I'm go okay right so
he's talking then he takes out a Cigar
Case this is 19 uh 18 or 1920 on it and
it's like a perfectly leather thing and
we're talking to him and he's talking
very weird to us and then he tried to
curse hold on hold on it gets crazy I'm
dude I'm on board okay but listen so all
of a sudden now and look again I don't
know what I saw but I'm telling you what
I felt okay I could tell you what
and and he goes he goes uh he starts he
tried to curse and it didn't fit he said
[__] when he was talking to us and it
felt as though it was somebody trying to
talk like us right and he goes so so he
starts so me and me and the dude are
just talking we didn't we go we asked
his name he said his name was Jacob
right didn't say anything else we didn't
take a picture nothing and then he said
something like okay well you gentleman
this and that and we're talking and he
leaves and he starts walking and I put
my right as he walks right so right now
say right now he starts walking at this
moment right right now right now and I
just go dude that was weird the other
guy goes he goes dude what the [__] was
that and then the other dude that I was
with just looked up and he goes Paul
Paul look at that [__] dude look how far
he got dude he glitched ahead dude this
[__] was 20 cars down in it was
I looked up now I let it go after I was
like I was like that's a little weird
his name is Jacob he's a locksmith and a
silent or an actor and he's got a limp
in the cane but I looked up and what
would have taken any of us for what
would have taken us what would you say
what would you say if you're walking 10
seconds he'll get you maybe four cars
down in the parking lot four looked up
this [__] dude was down and gone and
he's the one that saw it he goes Paul
look how far he is and then I freaked
the [__] out so then I go dude that's
not normal this dude and he was limping
and he had a cane so then we went out
and timed it so we went out to the
parking lot B Busters now now gr now
granted I'm now now granted now granted
I'm drunk at the time now
now no no that are you cocaine no no no
now no no no now I'm drunk at the end of
like he already gone not drunk but like
I had a butt so I go dude let's let's
time that so we we we walk and it was it
was not even close to how far this guy
was there was no it was like this guy
would had to be on a [__] moped to
get where he was and that's just and it
didn't even come from me it came from
the dude I was sitting with I go that's
really that's really really [__]
weird so then I told the story on the
podcast I FaceTime the guy that was with
me and I go hey I just told the story on
the podcast did I I said did I talk to
you before this he goes no I go go ahead
tell the story he tells the exact same
story that I tell yeah then a woman who
heard my podcast said that she was in
Arizona and she said she saw a man like
that glitch and get faster and do
something like that and then nobody else
has seen this guy again so my only thing
is this I don't know what I saw but to
me the way he walked the way he talked
and then he tried talking as if he was
like with the times of today with the
cursing that [__] me up I have
questions go ahead may I great story
great story by the way no no but that's
great story it's true and and if you
ever go to Phoenix I don't know if he's
still there but ask for the security guy
and ask what happened okay go I believe
you guys witnessed something yes I just
have a question sure oh my God what so I
just typed in Jacob time traveler yeah
no came up and read it with this this is
this this emblem ke popping up Jacob Von
hug Flume 1864 to 1909 inventor of time
travel oh dude this thing's popping up
oh that I didn't know wow that I didn't
know
okay now again I I think time well hold
on actually go the dark web but I I just
want to say I just want to say this for
your listeners yeah I don't think based
on what I saw that is definitely a time
traveler but based on what Einstein said
is possible
and and then seeing that I definitely
saw something awkward and out of the
ordinary so what you're saying to me
he's wearing 1920 attire full on so
you're saying that a dude from the 1920s
went to the
Future well yeah it couldn't be the past
I know but my point is so what you're
saying is that they had time travel when
you said time travel I thought oh some
guy in the future right walk by and says
the Broncos is going to win next year in
the Super Bowl right right right and
you're like oh [__] and then the sure
that they do win and you're like I met a
guy you so [__] Back to the Future
yeah yeah what you're saying is that
they had the capability in the 20s to go
into the future and he had the knowhow
to know what the future was like the
lingo you know what I mean all that
stuff what if the dude just can travel
time and he just [__] got comfortable
in the 20s and was just like I hop
around dress like you know maybe that
was his [__] maybe he's like I like this
so he's originally from the [__]
future well I mean I don't know where
he's from because he's a time traveler
he could be from anywhere why did he why
was he so far away two places he can be
from the future or the
past okay okay well you're not get I'm
getting this thank you you're seeing
time as a more linear all right now
we're going to go I'll [__] arrival
arrival arrival now I mean what what all
right so but could it be we're all in a
simulation and there's just a
glitch that you know what that could be
that's definitely something there like a
program that wasn't supposed to oh I
left one part out okay this guy wrote to
me and he goes hey I heard your story
about the thing my mother specializes
and things like this and she wants to
talk to you and then I was like I got a
little weirded out and then we never
spoke but she wrote me something and she
said I'd like to talk to you and it's
something that I would entertain but she
was basically saying how there's
Dimension holes that people can like tra
like her thing was this [__] and I I
didn't get in I don't know anything like
that but the only the only thing I would
say is this if I didn't see how far away
he got then I would go hey this could be
a looney like a just a loon who just
dressed like that walks around like that
and acts like that but when I looked up
and when he said to me Paul look how far
he is now and we looked up that's when
both of us go that's that's weird that
was how far he was was weird cuz you
couldn't get there especially with the K
I always think more not time travel more
like X-Men or like Marvel like
flash like I mean what or it could be an
alien thinking that's what a human is
it's like [__] [__] human yeah now you
freaked me out or it's Daniel it could
be the same [__] alien that was
hovering oh